welcome to this video I'm playing the
jedi jedi on this is the correct way to
pronounce it jedi master do they have
excelled in Dagobah so this is Yoda rod
so what do we do now maybe the Leningrad
reversed also I think it's also called
the pull-up beer they are right by
coined by Hendrick Danielson okay so go
before him Queen trait I don't think I
mind much looks fairly nice here can I
go he five quickly that looks a lot like
this big clamber opening that i recently
had Bishop e3 maybe sat on d4 my default
doesn't look too too problematic he just
play it however hmm maybe it was a
tricky thing okay let's go back
interesting
mossy old are really on Exile in Dagobah
what was he fleeing fleeing fleeing from
the Empire I guess okay um let's focus a
little bit on that game here Bishop a6
is probably coming mmm d for or not
probably
even though we definitely will can play
Bishop a 69 perform I have I have some
central place so can't have it all yeah
I thought night before might be might be
interesting but okay it's not that that
possibility is not gone for him here
write a five night BTW to maybe
ok 95 debatable
yeah I don't know that there's an
interesting position I've got the center
but he's got active pieces got the sea
fowl that's some definite and guru felt
flavor this position ok let's go here
see shooting from b5 and that would be
very interesting to play maybe
95 is something that I have have as an
idea oh it's not doing anything against
it I don't know if it's so great down
maybe this move
I wonder I wonder I wonder I wonder
maybe I should take Queen takes it's not
so clear that it is so great i have g5g
five ed ship that ok took with that at
least this gives me some freedom there
may be still 95 here why not that it
looks nice it should be five and queen
before I guess well Jesus ok
again I got something not even for me
but at least someone from my from my one
of my neighbors at this one I'm tried to
say we'll get something okay what now I
can also go a 326 I did not expect bit
irritated by this distraction I maybe
have six now I know hey I should have
taken simply okay not f6 so rooks you
one
threatening Luke take c8 little check
tag you he did look for that so look out
for that let's take
and now e5 huh getting i'm opening up at
the ever to bishop I'd really should be
right oh I just blundered a three oops
oops that's a big one and completely
completely unnecessary really it was was
really okay this position probably even
good my bishop t6 I really have to go
back I really have to go back even okay
with a howler what a howler I just give
him a 3m
still 494 maybe there isn't even clear
this position even a porn down it's not
clear
they have some compensation him off to
e6
also 97 is on here we go okay so he
returns the pawn okay let's see yeah
okay and of course if you takes this
phone will be quite nice Wow
and and end up winning that's it c7 root
dead while we completely spoil it
black resigns Jim guy I just blundered a
34 for no particular reason okay let's
let's look here free let's look about
look from here it should be okay for
white already geez stinks I'm surprised
the engine is giving white a huge
advantage plus one about with Quincy to
whatever yeah I like that yarn I'm
nicely centralized but this is this is
already rubbish em that was that was
right after the top right it doesn't
help him okay maybe I would have played
it anyway with this is better because
the a to pawn is pretty safe it cannot
be attacked quickly i have basically the
same position as in the game but not not
without not not with the e3 porneia here
what is this i couldn't i could take the
six but ok this is not that terrible i
just have to go here and then keep this
thing protected and then it's I mean a
bit better for white probably due to the
space yeah that is that is his more yeah
Jim it's him those pieces are not good
yeah it's a bit better it's a bit better
the engine wants to take on e5 which is
like plain ugly but
it's a bit better for white again yeah
something like that after after a blonde
at the pawn my engine says equal here so
I really have some compensation as I
felt yeah I felt it it's not that clear
of course this is no serious analysis
but and now I'm getting a big advantage
this is a great move here that i did not
see a tall and wide windsor and
according to the comp Wow
check check yeah the discoveries yeah
those those pieces are super strong and
amazing okay I was glad to having the
point that I had to pawn back end and
I'm back in the game and here he has to
move the rock definitely this is this is
not this is not playable yeah wyd
winsome damn it must be the sea ponies
is super dangerous and rukia diem ruki
eight is ok check no and that that is
probably okay for black he's got got got
counted checks and computers a sequel
yeah I'm very willing to believe that
after after this yeah it is just lost
not not much not much to be said him
yeah interesting interesting game and
turn tricky yeah the opening I think
this kind of this kind of thing is quite
interesting I don't know maybe Bishop e3
is not not the greatest yet you form
maybe actually I was hearing this but
this is this might be interesting I
would have a good diagonal down and this
is kind of blocked maybe yeah he's
moving as well this is a very similar to
last in the closed Sicilian now that's
okay I'm like ass blackest okay em yeah
but it was an alternative to work to be
sure where to okay well thanks for
watching